hello and welcome to this video on
playing George such no take-backs that's
good Alex I Yvonne off evil office /
only what are the most frequent names in
Russia so I'm just playing in a very
classical way and the the Catalan
opening here I have a funky sideline
available Queen d6 since an almost
unknown line but it is something that
I've used her with success in blitz
chess one key idea is that relatively
quickly black often gets this opposition
going look against Queen and this is not
so easy to play for wide threatening
c-5m the Queen on a six a somewhat it's
somewhat exotically placed but it's not
that bad cannot be attacked easily and
sometimes fulfills a useful role ok so
I'm going c5 that's the idea
hmm yeah he clearly doesn't like this
position until I i definitely understand
understand this feeling it so it's
probably comfortable for black here i
have also very easy moves that's
important in blitz that you don't have
to spend ages to find to find something
suitable but you can play quickly an
interesting moment here md5 is an
interesting move 95-90 xe5 bishop a 892
d3 this looks quite interesting rupee to
whom probably not objectively good yeah
so let's display in normal stuff ideas
to go bishop eight regroup like that the
group c 8 bishop yade to classical set
up against the IQ p this is a very
uncommon version of the IQ p in regards
to peace placement with them both
bishops via cathode this isn't isn't
really happening often okay if I take
now go bishop c6 he's going to sacrifice
the Queen I guess EF Ruby one but that's
not really working right and I don't
think so
don't think you can sacrifice the Queen
iya for enough compensation and if you
cannot do that that should be very okay
for me so where to go 95 I guess Bishop
takes you one EF six okay let's go to
divine one ideas night before 93 now the
light squares are quite vulnerable well
I've got some time advantage that's nice
I think that um Lucas e8 first is better
to have that rook Queen on line up in
the sea fowl it's not quite clear to me
where his queen is supposed to go
yes that's possible I mean I hope we
should be five I think I'm doing this
just play it simple maybe it was too
simple I don't know but it is good for
black I mean so nothing nothing to worry
about
so how to do the snow--look d3 that's
also typical move try to get in more
forces yeah so here rock d3 with the
tempo this is interesting look see one
Queen c5 attacking ok here goes away
attacking this um here I have routed to
coming though it doesn't feel entirely
great wow really this is a cheeky to say
the least
okay so what now Bishop c5 just getting
rid of this all looks into books into
Bishop e3
chef c5 cheeks rook c5 look T 1 he might
just hold this
am I just about hold this
books into should be three Bishop c5 is
interesting I think things yeah maybe I
have to play it at some point Ron King
stinks are the same it should it should
be good I mean I was thinking Bishop did
to rook t2 but then he might have
Queenie form to just about hoard but we
should be to Queen d2 I think should win
as f2 was hanging and impossible to
defend
well I don't see a defense we should
have to and then Bishop g3 show to check
should kill or just go back yeah pick up
your phone that should be winning right
check yeah screen g2 mate or here
Queenie III mate checkmate yeah that
looked like a good game i think he got
into trouble out of the opening and yeah
I don't really know what the best
continuation is cf44 white I think they
go night III as well but it's it's it's
just a funky line that I play in blitz
it's not that i know it a lot ok c 5
this should be true and here i feel i
should be okay I mean he's getting this
i QP on d4 and it doesn't really feel
that why does sound having much went
here Teague's okay now the engine gives
this I know Bishop e7 oh that's a good
idea of course I didn't think about that
I was only thinking about this fancy 95
but couldn't really make that oops that
was ha and we're going to finally
blunder right he can take okay but it
seems that this is in fact a playable
move quite interesting now I'm
threatening Knight f3 and on Knight d2
i'm going 93 the engine wants to sec the
green and gives it to label the term
about equal okay so what did actually
happen i took and now again be five was
interesting yeah probably better than
what i did but this is not this is not
bad it leads to a good position for
so we went here 95 yeah here this is
really debatable but should be five and
I think it keeps some advantage but this
is really far more logical keeping stuff
on the board hmm yeah the engine is
right of course yeah this is better and
there are also some quick ways for y to
do some in something like this it's
probably made in X and but okay I mean
I'm keeping an edge but it's it would
have been better otherwise why is black
battle I've got that great night and we
we see what happened after the trade
threatening this and he's called
weaknesses on the light squares that
Bishop is also not very good so we have
this and rook c8 here yeah now invasion
time h5 is a typical device to provoke a
weakening yeah the ideas h4h three and
then operate with this meeting idea so
why'd he have held him inclined to play
age 4 but this is weakening a scheme
position even more roop d3 the idea here
was he went went here if he goes rook
see one i have i was thinking that this
might be an idea intending here but he's
got this one jack this is not so great
yeah so Luke's you want to have to UM
have to play something something else I
was also thinking about just 25 to stuck
normal move that keeps keep things under
control note that there are also a
number of end games that would be better
for black because his pawns are on dark
squares bishops Bishop endgame for
example even though better in this case
does not mean winning
okay here oh here you missed the defense
Ruby one so Queen d5 wasn't the best
rope dat horse better this is given by
the computer this and this and this will
win yeah yeah open the floodgates and
like it's just invading with all his
force yeah taking that partner was
cheeky rookie to we'd be one and here
yeah so Roxy one is the defense that
seems to be okay for white yeah by the
way I was really only anticipating but
should be three but while I almost pre
moved or pre dropped Bishop c5 I was
thinking that Bishop back I mean from a
seventh this protective too so this is
definitely a move check and so this is
given as a possible line check can the
engine calls this equal but this
movement black going for some kind of
Perpetual I think I'm threatening this
this is why the engine gives this and
this is a draw and this is losing now
right yeah Bishop c5 is minus six so i
was i was doing an okay job here Queen
f2i Queen d2 bishop eft also seems to
win but can easily be some kind of
transposition yeah he really has no
defense now everyone's I hear chance
made made in two moves yeah and that was
still a decent game I gave him some
chance there was rook see one but I'm
still happy with how how i did thanks
him
okay thanks for watching